F: Salut !
Aujourd'hui je suis avec Aude G-G
Je dis Aude G-G ou Aude Gogny-Goubert ?
A: Tu dis tout ce que tu veux.
F: Vous l'avez vu dans golden moustache, dans le palmashow, sur comédie, au théâtre, dans d'autres web-série, euh....
les photos nues sur internet.
A: Si, ils ont vu tout ça, je les adore déjà
F: C'est vrai *rire*
A: Déjà si, ils ont vu tout ça déjà vous êtes formidables
F: Je me suis dis qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec Aude,
parce que forcément je vais essayer de la bluffer mais je vais essayer de vous bluffer en même temps
et je me suis dis...
A: J'ai le droit de dire que je suis fan?
*Rire de Fabien*
A: Moi je suis fan de Fabien Olicard
Oui je suis fan de Fabien Olicard
F: Et quand j'ai cherché sur Google
je me suis dis "je vais m'inspirer en reprenant un peu tout ce que tu as fait"
et... je suis pas allé très loin
j'ai tapé sur Google
Aude Gogny-Goubert et j'ai regardé les suggestions, que me proposait Google, de recherche
et en suggestion
j'ai eu...
Aude Gogny-Goubert copain, Aude Gogny-Goubert couple et Aude Gogny-Goubert compagnon
*Rire d'Aude*
Ta vie sentimentale passionne les gens
A: C'est abominable
F: C'est ouf... Regardez
A: Mais c'est fou apparemment demandez moi directement, je vous le dirai
F: Aujourd'hui je vais te proposer de faire un rencontre
mais une rencontre virtuelle
tu vas rencontrer un mec virtuellement
euh... ça va être ton chéri virtuel dans une autre dimension
A: D'accord
F: Sache que ce qu'on va faire pour moi c'est une galère
c'est à dire que c'est une première comme souvent les trucs que je fais sur la chaîne
on va voir ce que ça donne ou pas
j'espère juste y arriver à un moment donné
Je... j'hésitais
soit à te faire rencontrer quelqu'un virtuellement
et essayer de t'influencer dans le choix de... d'un prénom de personnes,
soit essayer de le déduire.
en fait, j'ai pris la décision que ça serait à mi chemin entre les 2.
A: D'accord
F: Donc on verra si j'ai bon ou pas
donc il y aura 3 solutions au final:
Soit je me plante complètement
soit j'ai bon que sur la moitié du prénom
soit j'ai tout le prénom
A: D'accord
F: Et si j'ai tout le prénom tu voudras plus jamais me parler
A: Ah ben euh...
F: Oui c'est ça
A: Ou je foncerai voir toutes tes prochaines représentations
F: C'est ça
A: Pour essayer de percer moi même ton secret
*Rire de Fabien*
F: J'ai une question "Est ce que tu me fais confiance?"
A: Mais oui bien sûr
F: OK alors ferme les yeux
A: J'ai très peur mais je te fais confiance
F: C'est juste détends toi complètement
A: Attends je ferme les yeux mais je me protège le visage
*Éclat de rire de Fabien*
A: C'est un bon deal
F: Je filme moi aussi pour voir ce qu'il se passe quand j'ai les yeux fermés
A: OK je ferme les yeux et je me détends
F: Ferme les yeux...
je pense que tu as une bonne imagination?
A: Oui
F: Alors, j'ai envie que juste tu t'imagines dans une ruelle
c'est la ruelle que tu veux, à l'époque que tu veux,
elle est vraiment comme tu veux, t'es dans une ruelle
tout est sécurisant autour de toi, il y a rien de spécial
et on est plutôt en fin de journée néanmoins
si il y a des lampadaires, ils sont allumés. Si il y a des fenêtres d'ouvertes elles sont allumés etc...
et au bout de cette ruelle
sur la gauche, il y a un bar
et ce bar, la devanture du bar est un petit peu verte
A: D'accord
F: Tu va devant le bar. Tu le reconnais?
A: Oui
F: C'est un bar que tu as déjà vu d'accord et tu vas rentrer à l'intérieur
et maintenant c'est toi qui va m'expliquer où est le comptoir.
est ce qu'il est en face de toi, à gauche, à droite. Explique moi comment est fait un peu ce bar.
A: Alors... le bar est en face à droite, en fait
F: D'accord
A: contre le mur. enfin oui c'est bête ce que je viens de dire
il est en face à droite
et il y a pleins de tables tout autour
euh... voilà en face de moi c'est une sorte de grand rectangle
F: Ouais
A: Il y a que le comptoir qui va vers le fond
comme si il y avait un couloir quoi
F: OK d'accord.
Je vais commencer à noter des petites choses moi de mon côté
A: Alala
F: C'est un serveur ou
A: Je suis sûre que tout se voit sur mon visage
il y a marqué le prénom sur mon visage
F: C'est un... c'est... un serveur ou une serveuse?
A: C'est un... c'est, il y a quelqu'un au comptoir et  il y a une serveuse
en salle
F: Et c'est un homme au comptoir?
A: C'est un homme au comptoir
F: D'accord OK
euh... tu vas regarder... cet homme là
et j'aimerais que tu imagines qu'il est pas très sympa, un peu agressif, qu'il parle mal, tu vois
A: D'accord
F: Tu vas discuter avec lui, tu...
juste tu lèves la main pour commander
et en fait... il te répond "Oui ben chacun son tour, vous avez pas 5 minutes"
Qu'est ce que tu lui réponds toi?
A: Pardon Excusez moi *rire* je crois que je m'excuse
F: Tu t'excuses?
A: Oui
F: Tu te laisses marcher dessus
A: Ouais
F: Par cet homme
A: Oui parce que je suis surprise
F: D'accord
A: quand je suis pas surprise, je suis préparée, je suis armée mais quand je ne le suis pas je m'excuse
F: OK... OK... du coup il y a quelqu'un qui vient d'aborder
qui vient te parler
c'est plutôt un beau jeune homme en tout cas c'est complètement ton style
dans cette réalité là, d'accord
Et... il se met à parler avec toi de la pluie et du beau temps
du soleil, du temps qu'il fait, de ce genre de chose d'accord
et en plus il commence à discuter avec toi de choses et d'autres et
du fait qu'il aime pas trop le serveur, il a vu comment il t'avait parlé. C'est inadmissible
il est pas très sympa avec toi et il est même un peu con tu vois
ça lui plait pas des masses
et du coup lui il va te payer un verre sur la bouteille qu'il a
A: D'accord
F: Comme ça tu n'attendras pas
F: Et toi tu vois bien qu'il y a quelques choses qui se passe
entre toi et lui
F: Attends j'ai le téléphone qui sonne en même
*Rire d'Aude*
F: Toi tu vois bien qu'il y a quelque chose qui se passe et...
A: Ouais
F: et que ça va être le début d'une grande relation
virtuelle parce que tout ça c'est dans ta tête
A: Bien sûr
et tu lui demandes son prénom
et du coup il te donne son prénom, ce chéri virtuel.
Comment s'appelle-t-il?
A: Faut que je te le dise?
F: Ouais
Alors t'inquiète pas
tu vas pouvoir le dire moi je l'ai marqué
A: C'est vrai?
F: J'ai marqué quelque chose ici
A: Ouuuh donc là je te le dis?
F: Ouais
A: Il s'appelle Constant
F: ll s'appelle Constant
A: Ouais
F: C'est marrant qu'il s'appelle Constant
A: J'ai le droit d'ouvrir les yeux?
F: Parce que moi j'avais d'écrit juste là sur ce papier
tiens je te le donne ici même dans les mains
et tu peux ouvrir les yeux
et j'avais exactement marqué Constant
A: Non mais c'est pas possible
*Éclat de rire de Fabien*
F: Est-ce que ça va?
A: Non ça va pas du tout
mais enfin, et tu vas m'expliquer quand même
F: Alors... Non
ça tombe bien que tu le dises, parce que ça fait partie de la série de vidéos qui
A: Oh l'arnaque
F: Sont en fait pour bluffer la personne qui vient, pour les bluffer eux aussi
puisque je passe mon temps à leur expliquer des choses j'ai...
j'ai envie de temps en temps de bluffer tout le monde d'un coup
A: Mais c'est même pas un prénom, enfin je ne connais personne qui s'appelle comme ça
F: Ouais
A: Et puis surtout j'ai changé d'avis à la dernière seconde
F: Alors...
A: J'avais décidé Antoine et je me suis dis Non non il faut un prénom un peu compliqué
F: C'est vrai? C'était Antoine au départ
A: Oui
F: Cool parce que Antoine ça aurait pas été possible pour moi
A: Et je me suis dis faut que je trouve un truc un peu plus compliqué pour le challenger
ça ne le challenge pas du tout
Je n'ai aucun secret pour cette homme
*Rire de Fabien*
F: J'ai décidé quelque chose maintenant, j'offre un carnet à tous ceux qui viennent
A: Ouais
F: C'est un trip avec les abonnés de la chaîne.
donc euh voici un carnet Rhodia
A: J'ai un cadeau trop bien
F: Tu pourras dire "Oui il a trouvé"
A: Attends je regarde si il ne m'a pas mis la vraie solution du truc
il a peut être mis tout les prénoms
F: [Chuchotte] Regarde
A: Mais il y a tout les prénoms
F: J'ai juste à la dernière seconde changé de feuille
A: C'est pas vrai
F: Mais c'est que là tu es en train de lancer ta chaîne à toi Youtube
A: Oui je vais lancer ma chaîne YouTube bientôt
F: C'est trop bien
A: Ouais je suis contente. Ça fait peur en même temps
F: Elle s'appellera comment la chaîne?
A: Alors euh la chaîne ça sera mon nom
parce qu'elle est déjà créée et que je ne sais comment on crée un autre compte
La première vidéo ne sera pas encore sortie mais vous pouvez déjà vous abonner en anticipation
F: Exactement
A: Ça c'est chouette
F: Exactement, exactement tu sais que, il y a Pierre Croce qui a fait ça pour Greg Romano il y a quelque jours
A: Ouais
F: Il y a un ou deux jours
et... et... Greg du coup... c'est dans quelques mois qu'elles vont sortir
c'était pour tourner au YouTube Space à Paris et
A: Ouais
et donc il y a besoin d'avoir 10 000 personnes qui suivent la chaîne
A: Absolument
F: Il est à 50 000, je crois, 55 000
alors ça ne sera pas le cas là
*rire de Fabien*
A: En même temps sur ma chaîne il y a déjà toutes les playlists de tout ce que j'ai fait auparavant
F: Et ça c'est pas mal. Alors je vous mets le lien vers la chaîne de Aude
et même si le nouveau projet n'est pas encore sorti, il y a toutes les playlists avec tout ce que Aude a fait auparavant
et ça s'est mortel. Vous pouvez déjà vous délecter de ceci
Merci beaucoup.
Qu'est ce que j'avais d'autres à dire...
ben que le Mental Vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
donc rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !